4:4 say we can sleep with our
slaves right there the right hand
possessed yeah so what is the problem
with
that sleeping with slaves first they
would use the term slaves that's the
term came from the European someone that
you you know beat
around no don't say that don't let don't
let the Western criteria to be over your
head the Islam ceria is above okay so
yes of course above any Western ID any
ideology easn Arab ideology Islam is
above everything so you look at our
civilization in comparison to the rest
of the world sitting there saying you
know which civilization do want black
people black people yeah want black
black people I think you no that're
mization no
h they to fight for they to fight
for it wasn't given to us like that so
hang on hang on hang on so let us go
back when the
slavery the law of abortion slavery can
you teach us what happened to the slaves
and what happened to the owners slaves
and owners I couldn't tell you br me
personally I couldn't tell you I've
never owned a slave no no I'm not
telling you that you haven't studed Bri
history no not really okay I'll teach
you so we the slaves not just in Britain
America believe it yeah about you can go
check it when the the law of abolishment
of slavery came into practice the slaves
were left without any money no treatment
nothing the owners was given comp
compensation you know for example one of
the the's the family which is one of the
richest family what's
name yeah they how they become rich
through slavery yes so so so now when
you talk
about we have
[Music]
called
M let me tell here so like he said they
had to fight for it said SL had to fight
for their lives they were tortured they
were they were they were they were
treated worse than animal are you of
that you of the zoo human
Zoo so to talk about to come and try to
teach us or talk to us about sa in Islam
I think you I respect you should be the
last
that you like white people weren't
slaves I didn't say that so you know
everyone's been a slave once Generations
once in their life when you go back to
history yes before for example the Roman
time the the Arabs time everyone slaving
everyone everybody was enslaving
everybody no doubt about that but
through the history according to my
knowledge of the there's no
SL or slave master
tortured
and Andy like the West how they to the
African you not agree with
thatv I'm
lie no no no no Islam Islam Islam No No
Islam let me I tell
you a nice you know the way you
coming what's your name my name
me so I would say to you in islamy is
forden
ande mammad told us Prophet Muhammad
said
anyone Muhammad said anyone that goes
around and kidnap people and sa them his
prayer will be accepted prayer be
accepted the other
word three of people their
opponents I
told I'm going to break it down so
soam said of you are speaking he he said
he said he said he said what they call
it
new
say, stward 3,000 people that are Allah
oppon one of them is someone that go
people that's why the SCH is originally
people are born to be free no one should
be no one yes no one shouldave no one
with me no one that's so whated Islam
came like you was saying everybody was
inav everybody or everybody doing and
everything yeah Islam came with
servitude servitude only in a time of
War not somewh no in a time of war in a
time of War Allah like gave four options
to the Muslim this not a group of people
mentally Disturbed coming to Britain or
go to America kidnapping people say no
people walk in the street so four
options what are they in the time of War
First Option the war hostages either you
fre them you would me pay attention pay
attention don't worry about the so four
times people yeah four options Allah
gave to the Muslim
leaders okay one of them take the the
the war prisoners either you let them go
free mam did it okay yeah did let go
free and you just said you don't have
enough knowledge about Islam yeah so he
did and you can go back check it
whatever I'm going to say I'm always
in YouTube you can come check me up yes
do resarch so the other one you exchang
with the other prisoners all right the
third one you ask for compensation money
the fourth one here we're coming in so
there's Islam State servitude is not
compul no no no no this not kill
business no because
you no no because why remember it's a
war
time what's the point around K just
don't make sense to me I don't believe
no
wor in the time of war the Muslim
leaders look at what is the best for
them okay so are you telling us when
British government cat
Isis uh uh prisoners they should let him
go
free obviously not let go free ah so
what what about the other coming to K us
and they K Muslims they're not going to
them they're not going to
Tres they going to do they do don't know
about exchanging
prisoners exchange prisoners no you know
is now in country you know about
exchange of prisoners wild sending
different jail no exchanging for
example sometimes they ask for
money are different things
no I hope you're honest person because
I'm talking about prisoners in war so
how to deal with them I let them go free
which is so what is how the Muslim
leaders have to look what is the best
interest for the Muslim Community so
give is say no we ask for money it's not
exchange them now come you keep as a
servant you treat the way treat yourself
okay you take care of them Prophet
Muhammad said you're not allowed to beat
them all right yeah he said that so now
this the only time you can have
in Islam when you have a servant in
Islam you allowed to raise money and to
pay the master to let him go free also
there is many ways to let them go free
for example if I say I'm going tomorrow
I'm going to go to France and I don't go
to France why do to break to to fulfill
my promise I let I have a servant I let
him go
free
emancipate mamm if you let servant Go
free the reward is Paradise so Serv
Islam is not like the Western World
rather the servant Islam they treat
better than some people here yes so s
Islam there's nothing wrong with it why
do you waste your time in Islam there's
nothing wrong with
it and it's a war time it's a war in a
war yeah War are you Christian by
way to me the
Bible am you accept the Bible to be the
word of God so in the Bible section
people
obvious it there's more it no it was
worse than that no more to it is
more you to never said that never said
that he said if you have a slave you
should slave should be very obedient to
his
master here I'll show you here I'll show
you Jus never set to free
SL
and slavery in the Bible was because of
because of because of Lish it's not
because of in the war you know if you're
Israelite you should be
enslaved all right
here uh what they call it Paul about the
staves obviously what else did Jesus say
cheat them like you you know love them
like you love yourself I never had said
love what the hell I know You' heard it
I know you've heard certain vers from
the of course I know Jesus said love
your enemy yeah yeah I know about that
but I know this teaching no one
implemented in reality doesn't make any
sense because we know that the Western
World they never showed in the is
following Jes I'm talking I'm talking
historically speaking I can tell you
that you should know that you're in the
western world you're obviously not
following the way it is no you
understand we not the Western World by
the way I'm not speaking about you son
I'm not speaking about every English
person or person most people think Queen
Charles is following following
Jesus I know he's not following Jesus
you missing the point here I'm say
historically speaking the Western World
who from day one they adapted
Christianity they never Implement that
teaching give me an example okay let's
go to Constantine Constantine he used
the Christianity belief to justify his
War yeah that's what he said he he saw
the cross behind the Sun what behind the
Sun the cross yeah he he saw the cross
behind the Sun and he justified the war
against people by using the the
Christianity all I know is that
obviously if you're not following Jesus
love them like you love yourself then
obviously that's not you know go out and
spre love if you're not following that
you're not following Jesus are you so no
one really follow Jesus is well you
don't see me got out there killing
people come on if someone you sister
obiously I'm not going to let that
happen am I that's love you should bring
your da didn't say let it happen did he
he didn't say let said if it is going to
happen then but you're allowed to do
something about it so you're going to
show love well obviously not at the time
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying so we have to agree with each
other he's your enemy though but Jesus
says love your enemies yeah so he's your
enemy should love him you know for a
certain way but obviously that's what I
saying these teach you know I mean I've
been through that sort of thing I know
you know mean I've had I've lost someone
through that sort of um that's what I'm
saying you're going to do everything to
save them you understand Paul advising
sa but I know you're obviously not going
to stay but someone's getting you know
what I mean if you're going to watch
someone diad and obviously not
protect them know yeah that's what I'm
saying what I'm saying if Jesus said
love your enemy he did not specify did
he so any person who's your enemy I'm
not going to claim to be an expert on
the Bible I can tell you that yeah yeah
no no you can do
your look you can check you can do your
own check in but what we say to you that
teaching yes you forgive no doubt about
that like Allah for example I don't know
if you're aware what happened to me I
got rushed by four people yeah at night
time coming coming from from a musim you
know by my Muslim Brothers you
understand you know this very
bad way to for the non Muslims if the
non-muslims speaking even some
Christians told me how on the earth they
attacking you and you defending Islam
you know but anyway alhamd what I did I
said you know what let's carry on Allah
guide them I pray to Allah guide them
you understand that's how I do it don't
kill you makes you strong that's what
I'm saying bro I promise you to come
back but because they what happened to
me as I'm to come back then they gave me
life again to give more
da
face to face I would speak to them
iuss
you ask you that
question being a man and having a
discussion yeah
yeah of course but but Allah said what
forgive if you overlook yes you know
what I'm
saying
I you know I that but you know you even
know I do I would not do nothing but you
know what I should they they praise me
in the way you know why they praise me
they they knew they need four people and
guess me and even four people they had
to deceive me sounds like you're close
to Living Like Jesus
there sounds real close like you live
you know I believe in Jesus I believe he
was the best man walks up on the earth
at the time of his his lifetime you
understand let me get you the one man
sorry don't think
he read it was it Ephesians yeah a born
servant obey your Earthly masters with
fail and
tumbling said advising the the Masters
be nice to them be good to them look
after them once Prophet Muhammad he saw
a man is about to beat his servant he
said he did touch his Serv he said what
are you doing he said oh messenger Allah
let him go free you see and there was a
man during the life toh Muhammad he cut
off the private part of his servant said
go after him the man run away you know
some Christians to use this they never
finish the so the point here is
islamically speaking Serv Islam is based
upon mercy and Justice and wisdom but
the in the Bible is based upon
oppression there's also some things that
obviously mam did
that the
woman that woman that woman got TI to a
horse and ripped apart no that's not
true that's not true that's not
true that
story the same way I see online the same
on I what you doing you hearing people
saying it and it's good to verify it I
mean the fact we're having conversation
here that's why when I speak to
Christians I'm going to tell them I
believe Christianity is wrong cuz I was
reading the mirror the newspaper mirror
or the guardan because I'm use a Bible
and use that authentic and clear you
understand so so there's a lot of right
against our Prophet Muhammad you
understand now for example these guys
who rushed me maybe they're going to
even believe that's a teacher of
Islam those who Rush rushed me they're
going to believe maybe they believe
that's teaching of Islam that's not
teach of Islam to go Rush someone in
Islam one of the Prophet Muhammad's
companion he had the sword and he was
fighting the other person dropped the
sword he said he said go get your sword
firstar go get your
sword that shows you the man Islam
understand do you believe in Jesus God
start with you believe Jesus Is God and
God knows everything and wom and Jesus
know everything in the Bible Jesus said
time he didn't know know so he does not
everything at the time no but God knows
everything all the time God does it is
God you're going to mess about you're
trying to mess about me I'm raliz
I'm I'm not going to sit here thinking
on the spot yes
yes we're not speaking about some deep
subject speaking the most why
are why are the Jews
so I just want to make sure we
understand the so which Jesus Is God I
want to make sure we're on the same page
Spirit show me in the Bible
why are the Jews
so can I just use my knowledge
and you know how are you going to use on
your knowledge speak about something
beyond your knowledge Beyond yeah
because he beyond your knowledge okay
I'll tell you why yeah okay have you see
it with your own eyes Spirit claiming to
be God and want inside Jes body I claim
to see the spirit of God go inside you
haven't seen did Jesus tell you that in
the Bible doesn't say that I to you my
God
Mary yeah go God when you to Jesus sorry
St you say God impreg Mary what do you
mean by
that what do you mean like a man with a
woman obv
not he gave her a child that's the best
thing to utilize he gave a child yeah
and just like God gave what do they call
it um uh created Eve from Adam so that's
what Allah in the Quran told us simil of
Jesus
withus may
ask information from the Bible the Torah
and then implement it into the Quran and
yet all of a sudden it doesn't seem
right when it comes
Tov Cate Torah come first
come you taken information from that
and
Mis
interpretting about me when I have
discussion I use
theop the Bible or talk about me when I
speakr okay the Quan speaks of judgment
in details show me that in in the
T in details yeah we do see
I read the
thingly can't say that I'm Allah speak
about people we are the people in the
Bible Allah speak are the people in the
Bible however we believe genuinely
speaking there is some truth in the
Bible we believe that the Bible the
Torah and the was given to God by God
toes I've taken B from
it yeah and I've broken the first rule
that God's given which is thou sh not
have any other God before me so I've
basically created my own image of what
is yeah me personally I basically God's
going to sit there's going to know lives
he's going to sit there
and's done wrong there are no Jews there
are no blacks there are no are no men
areas forgive
you forgive you trying to say because
you had a hard life God going to take
into consideration you know that because
we say
I didn't realize that the fact is that
if I had have carried on going that way
and not realizing that Jesus dying for
my sins
is that's where I broke the First
Command you know so you I'm conf so
basically your own experience so
basically you following the wrong path
then you notice that even if you go
through a life that's not sufficient for
God to enter your Paradise you have to
believe di for
your unbelief however we're talking
about the nature of God I mean
about the you
have but doesn't make any sense to me
that God who perfect he knows everything
all the time become human being because
by definition human are created and
God's and created from what I've heard
obviously God had to do something to
show people that obviously there
sacrifices going on in you know before
we were born yeah sacrifice act of
worship the Moses and Abraham or Noah
and even Noah time there's no sacrifice
it was after to knowah when you
sacrifice a sheep doesn't mean the Sheep
is taking all your sins no it mean that
the act the sacrifice Act is an act of
worship and believe thatl we believe
that for example imagine you coming to
visit me in my house I got sheep I
sacrifice it for Allah then I save you
the
food isation of my and I'm getting that
doesn't mean my jump on the sh himself
and he's going to be
punished done that he's done the
sacrifice I have
have sacrif for to stop s s because
you're not perfect I can still yes not
perfect what I'm saying obviously I have
to stop
your yeah but I'm saying my point here
is that we're talking about the
foundation of God the foundation of
Islam and and and and and and and the
teaching of Jesus and all of that one
God I'm talking about one God focus on
one God before we're going to come to
that you you believe in one God to
distract your father Jesus
from together don't expect
me
expain like I said I'm not
someone that's G some Mega amounts of
research on this situation you know why
I'll tell you something here you know
what makes Islam so beautiful and so
attractive the Simplicity and the truth
and Mak sense in Islam simple there's
only one God who is that
God Allah is
is a master self-sufficient everything
is in need of him he's not in need of
nothing he be not neither would he
begotten there's nothing like unto Allah
he's the Creator the provider you're
probably not going to like what I have
to say there things that were in
the he's the provider the Creator the
strongest the more all powerful he's the
the he sent the prophets and Messengers
to teach us how to worship God and to
follow the best teaching to save
ourselves and to gain salvation we don't
believe that Prophet Muhammad is godet
we don't even allow anyone that pray to
Prophet Muhammad is not a Muslim you
have to pray to Allah we believe in
Jesus we believe in MO Moses we believe
all the prophets and Messengers came to
teach us how to worship the creator of
this tremendous creation you know and
Allah teach us you should be responsible
for your sins but remember Allah is full
of Mercy full of love and forgiveness
but also has anger and mighty that's why
based upon his anger and mighty create
the Hell Fire based upon his love and
mercy create
Paradise it sounds a lot like you know
you're preaching the Bible to me no I'm
not preaching Bible let go the Bible the
Bible is the father fully God is the
father fully God is Jesus fully God so
the father fully God yeah and the Holy
Spirit no is the father fully God and
the spirit no ask is the father fully
God yes so we have one God already we
have one God do you do you according to
you to
you you guys are trying to obviously
thing you've obviously had a lot
of discussions about
this my feet you know mean I'm just
getting my feet wet you know what I mean
does he make sense to you he's the
father fully God when he says fully God
means everything that we God possess the
father has it so we are not in need of
another God do we you're asking me to
explain what God is you know what I mean
can't explain it I'm not tell you what
God explain everything about yes I
should have gone and read a lot more
than what I know but there
certain things we know about God you and
I we can discuss it for example you and
I we know God is perfect I don't have to
study the whole Quran and the Bible you
know God is perfect so if someone tell
me god is perfect then he believes in
God that is not perfect that is
sufficient for me to say you know what
you don't making no sense I don't have
to have qualification from Oxford
University to come to conclusion believ
in god is perfect on the other hand
someone says yes but at the same time he
believes someone the God is imperfect
that doesn't make any sense so my point
to you the father is fully God correct
okay so look just not not to be rude
enough but this is where I lose faith in
in obviously you know Islam and things
like that when it comes down to Muhammad
before go to Muhammad
brother I can't I can't basically stop
myself from thinking at the fact that
the man married years a 6ye old years
old
exp I bet you have you know what I mean
expired that's expired you know for me
for hasn't for me that is cool no no
first I can't sleep with little girl I
can't sleep with little girl before you
go to sleep little he
didn't think you
think you are aiding him to
divert yeah yeah brother if you ask that
question it's going to bring another
question yeah brother I've been here 15
years so I know this tactic I'm going to
ask that question another question I
know may Allah bless
you say again whoever had a fight with
don't swear may Allah bless you you know
and may Allah bless for you jealous to
ask the question Allah bless you don't
swear they areow true but you know
firstly may Allah bless you for your for
the the tactic you have to understand if
you ask this question it's going to be
another question so you can everything
so we go back to the m firstly you are
staying here you have struggled to
accept someone get married to a girl
that 9 years old but you have no problem
to believe in God he became a baby you
believe in God he went inside woman
private
party why you God was doing inside woman
private private part what was God doing
inside the woman private party it's not
like he slept with did he no wa wait
wait he holy know Miracle is so so okay
imag same way same way you have been
brought into this you know mean someone
you have problem so I have no problem
for I have no problem for go to go
private play around like a baby
impregnate her no no go to impregnate
her who's old good her who older good or
the the
woman how old between them the AG so so
here the problem 40 years Gap he has no
problem with billion
years he what he did he got
pregnated he done his own way according
to you he he did according to you not
sleeping with her okay he got pregnant
it's not sleeping
did he ins his inside her listen
listen before you should watch the video
care care did did she get pregnant did
she get pregnant yes she did okay so
obviously so she got pregnant yeah yeah
and how you how she got pregnant by
obviously the same way that men women
getting sorry women get pregnant
men women get pregnant yeah but not
obviously SP yeah regardless what it is
so you justifying go to have to have to
get child pregnant cuz she's child
according to God God has not beginning
but did did God asked her did God asked
her did he asked her he asked her yeah
he spoke her wait wait wait so so you
have no problem to ask Prophet Muhammad
ask her did he yes no he he did she was
9 years old and tell you something about
history firstly so he has no for God to
get to get a girl pregnated to go inside
our private part and know be
honest too to listen to what she had
like to basically that's not true that's
not true because Fe they were scared to
lose their life no it's not true it's
not true you know the you know that was
you I'll tell you something I'll tell
you something you just doing what the
zist are doing the Zionist are killing
babies and children in Philistine Gaza
and they then they say we do to defend
ourselves look the double standard yeah
so the point here is let's go back to
the main point the main point here is
that Prophet Muhammad marriage firstly
she was 9 years old okay historically
speaking if you're not aware even
Britain around the world the girls there
to get aware way mature mature way
quicker all right and said when the girl
reach the age of nine is a woman all
right she's a woman and if I ask you
what differentiate a child and adult
what's the difference between a child
and adult obviously their mentality not
really all the time because mental
because okay in my country I was 11
years old when I had my own my business
yes that doesn't mean anyone at a
certain like kids at a certain age if
they get impregnated and obviously have
kids they can die from that because
their body isn't matured fully from it
yes you're you're right I'm a doctor but
this what way I'm hearing a lot of other
information no doctors you're wrong
because what if you go to doctors yeah
if you go to doctors when a girl reach
the age of puberty you allow me to I
mean there's many women dying after
giving her birth so we should stop woman
getting Mar 25 30 I know you're saying
there what I'm saying to that happen
dur for a child for a woman as well for
adult when I say child for adult that is
in the beginning okay for me there's no
convincing me that obviously I'm not to
convince you because why you know
remember Jesus Jesus
sorry no no no
no did Jesus convince
everyone did Jesus convin everyone who
he was the Messiah everyone so so what
the problem with Jesus teaching or the
the problem with the
people people the people so so if I
don't convince you the problem is not
with me it's with you okay because Quran
because first Allah told him to get
married to was at the age of nine and we
go now his scientifically based upon the
biologist believe
that's that's not what God would tell
someone to do no no okay okay okay would
God okay no problem would God tell you
to kill babies no of course not in the
Bible I know what you're saying yes I
know you're saying so so God said it or
not I know what you're saying you said
they didn't do it you said they didn't
do it they they they did they going and
kill
them said de what are you wasting your
time they they did it you know say look
look stud history
kids are being taught to go around
killing people obviously Unfortunately
they may not be thinking clearly
and God said to kill babies bro the
babies also you know in the Bible
Leviticus God said to Moses kill every
woman that St with the man and keep the
LI of God for yourself did he yeah
Leviticus where you going to do play
football together keep the little
girl I'm saying bro there's a lot of
information you know what the about your
culture but now now that it's matur and
obviously Jesus has come for and he's
obviously saying not to do these things
anymore well then things have changed
now that's not true that's what happens
with Christianity it doesn't stay the
same as as go by CH St Islam has stayed
the same and they're still trying to
keep it that way that's why the Bible
corrupted because you keep changing
according to people's
desires of course because people desires
is not stable people desire for example
change
the no no no it's not go see that you
picturing like that it's not like that
at all your no no no you picturing you
picturing something they ain't exactly
over 20 are they Sam Sam Sam my brother
Jamal his daughter she's taller than me
how old she 11 she's taller than me 11
she's than me for me so she was 9 years
old she was my but you're using your
Dynamics today's cult the
judge at the I am trying to fancy some
little
12 so said to do it right the God said
every woman that with a man and keep the
little G for your soul like I said
certain things happened in history I I
happen zo I know what was going on
during those time no was he I'm asking
why God made these decision I'm not
saying why or not was he right or wrong
that's the
question I'd have to say was right a it
it was right so you have no problem for
God to tell us sleep with the little
girls but did he say that he he said
kill every woman that slept with a man
slept with a man and keep the little God
for yourself but like I said to him as
well you know so did the people agree
with what obviously happened you know
they obviously may not have killed them
like I said if they wait wait wait wait
ask wait wait wait sorry Sam you miss
the point for about they agree or not
the question here is that is God right
to command in the first
place that's the question that's the
question yes I know indeed my brother
that's why CH experience in discussions
but coring point I ask Allah to guide
you you know we pray Allah to guide you
what the brother said is wrong to youzee
our social uh uh moral to to not just
Western our social moral and our time
because can't I can't give you the no no
wait wait I'm going to finish wait
please listen to this you know why
because even our time like the the the
culture British culture is not Universal
is it I said that this is the thing when
it comes to British culture I don't
exactly agree with
wayv the the same thing you say about
the Bible it's been corrupted so is
British culture now no I'm asking about
he's corrupt not is a British culture
Universal thing or not me personally
it's not Universal okay is it is it Russ
gr how many of you grown up in the UK I
grew up in the UK and would you say it's
a good place to grow up in no doubt
there's a lot of good things in
comparon no doubt there good things and
bad things in Algeria there good things
and bad things no doubt yeah but then
not will be because of why why before go
why you digress The Point again you see
you see my
brother culture culture again sorry
sorry sorry the British culture is
universal you said no is it LO logical
rational for someone to utilize British
culture to judge the people in our time
not back before just in our time is IR
rational logical for someone to use
British culture to judge the whole world
that's what I said
it's not it's not of course let alone SV
happened 1,000 years
ago that's what I'm saying let alone
happened 1,000 years ago so the case is
closed and I hope may Allah guide you
when you go home pray to the god of
Jesus and the god of Moses are you going
to do inshah you want to pray to the god
of Jesus know what that is pray to the
god of Jesus pray I don't pray you don't
pray so you don't believe
anymore take C
yourself